Johnston who was of course George HW
Bush's chief of staff and a central
figure in that administration and that
time really an American life and he
joins us tonight with his memories
governor thanks a lot for coming on what
are your memories of Barbara Bush well
she was a great lady and a great friend
and it's obviously a great loss
it's amazing how she was really the rock
of that family and they all acknowledge
it she held all the pieces together and
when I was in the White House I was
fortunate enough to end up with a great
relationship with her we had developed a
good relationship in the 88 campaign and
and you know she could see through
people she could sense the real people's
from the real people from the phonies
and I I think she sensed that I really
had the president's back and so we got
along really really well and it made my
life easy obviously but she for the
Priscilla was important it was important
to get along with her then boy it
certainly was that and the family knew
that more than anyone else interesting
her son the president the 43rd President
used to talk about her a lot with a
mixture of what sounded like love aw and
maybe a little bit of fear warrant I
think he called her the enforcer yeah
exactly but she really was an
exceptional person she didn't try to be
seen all around the White House but she
knew that whenever the president had a
tough decision the person that got his
ear last and made the biggest impact was
Barbara Bush and and she made a big big
difference that way so I want to put up
on the screen a statement we just
received from the president 43 george w
bush it says this my dear mother has
passed at age 92 Laura Barbara Jenna and
I are sad but our souls are settled
because we know hers was Barbara Bush
was a fabulous first lady and a woman
unlike any other who brought levity love
and literacy to us she was so much more
mom kept our kept us on our toes and
kept us laughing until the end I'm a
lucky man that Barbara Bush was my
mother
family will miss her dearly and we thank
you all for your prayers and good wishes
so I asked Britt this question you were
right the center of it how did Barbara
Bush manage to be as famous as she
wasn't she really was pretty famous for
a first lady more than most I think and
yet pretty widely liked on a bipartisan
level she never was controversial or
divisive and the way others had been
how'd she do that well the way you put
your finger on it she tried to make sure
she wasn't controversial or divisive she
was clear in her opinions people knew
where she stood she didn't straddle on
anything and I think people appreciated
the fact that what you saw was what she
was and and it really was like that from
from day one all the way through I I was
lucky enough to have a quiet dinner with
the President and mrs. Bush last month
and e-card and I went down and did an
event that at the bush library and the
president mrs. Bush asked us up into the
apartment they have there and and she
looked a little extra frail there but
but you know even in the condition that
we now know she was in it was a fun
dinner we had a talked about all times
we reminisced we laughed a little bit
and and we talked about what was going
on she never let her personal situation
impact the quality of the interaction
she had with people I mean she just
lived through the really the whole span
of modern American history 92 years she
was born before the Great Depression in
a world that no longer exists and then
she passes in the middle of a world that
is becoming something completely
different I wonder how she respond to
that what does she make of it
Tucker she not only lived through it she
helped shape it that's right and and I
think she was very aware of what a a
crucial time that she and the president
spent in the White House that was really
a hinge point post-world War two the the
catalyst had been set for the collapse
of the Soviet Union with Ronald Reagan's
buildup of of u.s. defense but George HW
Bush was the one that had really the
very delicate diplomatic skills to pull
it off as smoothly as it was pulled
the collapse of the Soviet Union and the
reunification of Germany and she was a
very active part of that whole process
her relationship with mrs. Gorbachev was
important her relationship with the
first lady's of the other superpower of
the other major nations around the world
was part of catalyzing the very personal
relationship that George Bush developed
and it was his personal relationship to
a great extent that allowed that process
to works so smoothly and she was a very
important part of that governor Johnson
knew the head of another famous
political family in this country thank
you very much governor appreciate it
thanks Tucker take care